رغم ان الغرب وتحديدا الولايات المتحده
يخشى نفهذا مخزونه من السلاح كما ذكرنا
لكن هناك ميزه لاستمرار الحرب وهي ارض
اوكرانيا هي حقن تجارب نظام الاثنين
البندقيه تقوم بتحييد المسيرات وفصلها عن
نظام الاقتصاد دخلت الخدمه قبل عامين فقط
وكبير حصلت على 50 وحده منها معتبره الامر
اولويه قسوه التجريبات عدت المعدات
الخفيفه المانيا سلمت اوكرانيا نظام
ايرستي النسخه الاحدث من النظام الدفاع
ولم تدخل الخدمه بعد في الجيش الالماني
سلاح اخر هجومي وهذه المره القوارب
المسيره الانتحاريه التي اكدت روسيا ان
اسطول البحر الاسود تعرض لهجوم بواسطتها
كيف لم تعطي تفاصيل عن الهجوم لكن مصادر
غربيه اكدت ان برلين واشنطن سلمت اسلحه
ممثله اوكرانيا ومن الاسلحه الى انظمه
المعلومات نظاما ثوري صوره الناتو
بالتعاون مع اوكرانيا استخدم في الحرب
لاول مره دلتا طور هذا العام ليشمل 30
ميزه يلبي متطلبات الحرب والنتائج مبهره
بحسب خبراء امريكيين لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
النظامي يقدم معلومات اوسع من كونه وسيله
انذار مبكر يجمع الخرائط الصور والصور
لمعدات العدو وعدد الجنود في الزمن
الحقيقي ويمكن ايضا دمج المعلومات التي
تصل من الاقمار الصناعيه وصور المسيرات
وحتى الصور التي تصل من المواطنين في
الميدان امورا جعلت فعاليته كبيره للغايه
ومكنه الاوكرانيين من كسب الوقت ومعرفه
متى واين يجب ضرب القوات الروسيه خاصه
[موسيقى]